[Musique]
retrouvez allons nous avec le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel ensemble faisons de
la réunion un territoire d'exception
bonjour et bienvenue dans l'émission
allons-nous l'émission ou sans sa
découvre la réunion ensemble vous allez
parler alors allons-nous
mon pays comme on y est la réponse avait
mis 1
alors hausse annulée dans la commune de
saint louis plus précisément à la
fenêtre des mac et nous nous ça démarre
le sentier il ça amène à nous hôpitaux
kabuno a fait un de ses allures autour
et si nos gars à bénodet à 1580 mètres
d'altitude alors le sentier l'idée m'a
pas là eh bien nous savoir le piton
cabris allez allons nous au moins six
enfants rien que ça même
si l'on retrouve moment
rien que la même au cannet
[Musique]
il ya un an mourir sur la transversale
comme si la nature déconner alala
paradis mots nous restons
en tout cas une magnifique vue à bien
des gens qui m'ont fait aller les voir
bonjour bonjour bonjour bonjour à tous
et allez vous alain m'a bien bonjour y
est ça va bien dites moi vous venez d'où
comme ça va de piton cabris d'accord je
vois que vous avez monsieur des bâtons
là il ya des bateaux est ce que c'est
une marque qui est difficile assez c'est
assez rude parce que c'est abrupte ça
monte ça descend donc le bâton sont les
bienvenus et du coup vous habitez la
région mais vous êtes en vacances non on
est en vacances vacances à saint gilles
à d'accord et pourquoi avoir décidé de
venir en vacances à la réunion parce que
tout le monde nous dit que ça
aurait été totalement mais combien
est-ce que vous coupez à mézin oui super
magnifique montagne mer super et la
suite du programme pour vous les
vacances demain on va faire un petit
survol en hélicoptère de l'île arrault
qu après on va aller voir les baleines
et après une plongée
mon pays comment il est
la réunion ça mais miyem valbonne
ap le respect pour mon pays il vraiment
après depuis son lit
goût de la terre neuve a dit aux gros
bras de mon pays
on
et
ben voilà nous ils arrivent au niveau du
kiosque et tombe bien à 2000 sous le
coeur ça nous va aller voir maintenant
bonjour messieurs dames comment allez
vous
voilà j'ai rarement condamnés souvient
qu'à coller on est bien à mes frais on
prend prend le frêle zabita la région
non nés en métropole ahdab de quel côté
écoutez bien haute saône vacants mu à sa
peine et pour moi on va venir à la
réunion alors ben est venu à réunion
parce que je suis réunionnais et puis ça
faisait longtemps qu'on n'était pas tous
vingtaine d'années je prends note en
même temps qu'on n'était pas venu on
regarde visite tout ce qu'on n'a pas pu
faire il ya 20 ans on fait maintenant et
est ce que vous faites souvent la
randonnée du coup oui mais nous le fait
d'un randonnée dans les alpes à 28
je fais beaucoup arrivent rouge en tout
cas c'est chouette
bonne continuation
[Musique]
en tout cas d'alain gaillard point de
vue nous a relaté mme petit instant
alors effectivement on en a tous la vue
sur soi si lorsqu'on est vitale à la
alors oh ça nous saute et hossa nourault
ça va alors nous nous sommes là-bas à la
fenêtre des mac alors l'histoire dit que
les marques qui doit son nom elle
l'imérien d'origine de madagascar le mât
qui varient au thé et ben ne va voir si
notre tour aller et 20 noeuds ça va
[Musique]
voilà nous la fait le petit à leur
retour sur les plus hauts cabri new
profile occasion que nous et là nous va
aller voir le point de vue de la fenêtre
des mac ne voit pas ce pas là allez
on puisse tomber d'année un joli petit
panneau est muet madame en train de
vérifier des chiots ont duré bonjour
dame oui bonjour monsieur mal et ça va
très bien eh bien oui bien bien bien
moins qu'on soit en train de faire un
petit pull noir ou en train de prendre
des notes vérité en train de vérifier un
petit peu tous les aménagements qui a
été réalisé sur ce point de vue dans les
travaux qui ont été réalisés par lohan
est d'accord financé par le département
et l'europe les travaux avaient été
réalisés c'est essentiellement la les
rambardes la table paysagère ce
cheminement pmsd mon film est un conte
d'hiver qui arrive sur un stationnement
une place de stationnement dédiées aux
personnes à mobilité réduite est ce que
nous nous gardons que sa nouvelle tu
peux pas pour la table de paysages oui
mais regarde ma montre un petit peu les
grands sommets alors piton des neiges
alors ici des que les juste ici
donc au lieu du village de cilaos oui
alors village aux néo lille et voilà
alors c'est noonan a le grand bénare le
grand baie n'a alors le grand ménage au
québec ils voient les liens et sur la
table d'orientation ici en 2008 198 m
entre les deux ouais là le gros morne
hockey à 3019 au débat super sa bonne
notation non
en tout cas le petit peu un but et était
gaillard route et bah nan des trois
engins au monde la
belle et bonjour bonjour dites moi vous
avez un drôle d'engin là on a un coin de
balcon adéquat de balkh ton ludique quad
bike c'est que exactement d'un être bien
spécifique des tubes a alors un quad
bike c'est un engin assez unique
français on peut résumer en disant que
c'est un vtt à 4 euros mais j'aime pas
dire ça parce que ça s'utilise pas du
tout comme un vélo en dehors du fait de
pédaler c'est pas du tout la même
pratique et puis ensuite découvrir la
forêt en quad bike c'est très c'est
assez unique parce qu'on a un engin qui
est totalement stable donc on peut en
roulant regarder ce qu'il ya à droite à
gauche dans les arbres la faune la flore
d'accord en vélo c'est difficile parce
qu'on est obligés d'être très attentif à
la moindre pierre au moindre trou
d'accord alors que là nous on peut
vraiment être concentré sur le panorama
et le ska autour de nous alors que
aujourd'hui c'est quoi le programme
alors aujourd'hui donc on monte au point
de vue à la fenêtre profit profiter de
la vue en buvant le café avec un petit
croissant ensuite on va redescendre
faire un peu d'initiation technique de
pilotage pur franchissement vraiment
tout terrain d'accord et quand on aura
fini ça on va descendre jusqu'à la piste
de la syrie qu'on va remonter en
pédalant avec encore une petite session
trial à mi chemin
côté moto calais matin à baup et à faire
pouffer pouvoir les vrais mois gaillard
ota long pour le temps visite à riom et
poussa rendez vous un prochain épisode
de l'émission allons-nous cette fois ci
ne sera dans la commune de saint joseph
nous sera accablant gagnaire semaine ma
pauvre
[Musique]
allons-nous vous a été présentée par le
département avec vous et pour vous le
département agit pour la préservation du
patrimoine naturel
[Musique]